مره اخرى تعود الطواقم الطبيه في الصين
الى خط المواجهه هذا ان تركته اصلا فموجه
كورونا التي ضربت البلاد بعد تخفيف القيود
تركت المستشفيات مكتظه بالمصابين نصفهم
تقريبا حالتهم حرجه ووفقه صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز المرضى يستلقون على الارض ويحتشدون
في كل زاويه وركن في اقسام الطوارئ وامامه
ابواب المصاعد واضافت الصحيفه ان
المستشفيات كانت مقتده بالفعل وتعاني من
نقصه في التموين ونقصا في الموظفين في
افضل الاوقات لكن تخفيف القيود دافع عن
نظام طبي الى اقصى حدوده
زياده ساحقه في اعداد المرضى مقابل نقص في
المعدات الطبيه والموظفين المرهقين اساسا
لا سيما ان العاملين الصحيين في الخطوط
الامانيين 100 يوكافحونه العدوى المتفشيه
داخل صفوفهم وقد تثبت او ثبتت اصابه
الكثيرين من هؤلاء بالفايروس في بعض
المستشفيات لدرجه ان العام مجبر على
القيام بمهام خمسه من زملائه ليه ضمان
وجود عدد كاف من الموظفين على الارض تخلت
بعض المرافق عن مطالبه الاطباء والممرضات
باختبارهم انفسهم قبل العمل
كانت الحاله اليوميه تتراوح ما بين 300
الى 400 مريضه بينما وصل العدد امس الى
الى عياده الحمه في حين وصل عدد المرضى
ذوي الحالات الحرجه الى مستوى عالي في
الاسابيع القليله الماضيه كان المرضى من
الفئه الاولى والفئه الثانيه يمثلون 10
الى 15% من اجمالي الحالات لكن الان وصلوا
الى 40%
لكن ذلك بالتاكيد لا يمكن ان يواكب الطلب
الحالي لذلك قام مركز الخدمه لدينا
بتجميعه كل معدات الرعايه الاحتياطيه
المنتشره في اقسام اخرى بالمستشفى لتضاف
الى بنك الموارد الجديده الخاص بنا لانقاذ
العنايه المركزه